Good day to you, sir.
How may I help you?
The Barber said I have
"Delirium of the Bowels,"
but the bloodletting's
just made it worse.
Well, you've come
to the right place, sir.
No need for any more barbaric
or outdated procedures.
Our chief of surgery
and his team,
they are the best
in the nation.
If you come right this way.
Dr. Thackery, I have
your next patient here.
(chair squeaks)
Then the game is on.
(kids' voices)
Junior!
The patient is
a 38-year-old man
with an acute infection
in his lower bowel.
Untreated, his condition
will quickly deteriorate.
I'll make an incision thusly.
(sniffs)
Ahh.
And then operate using
a revolutionary method
of my own design.
Nurse Elkins, scalpel.
(squishing sounds)
Pulse increasing.
Scissors.
Pulse stability dropping!
We're losing him, Thackery.
Let's hope to God this works.
(Kid Chickering)
We've lost his pulse!
(Kid Gallinger)
Thackery, it's over.
No!
He just needs more glue!
We've lost him.
Damn it!
(grunts)
You're not supposed to have
those before dinner.
Shut up!
I want more Pixy Stix!
(screaming)
Oh, dear.
Right this way.
Dr. Thackery, in light
of today's... events...
the Board of Directors saw fit
to hire an additional
chief of surgery.
Like hell!
The Knick is mine!
Dr. Thackery, please.
Mine!
No, it is mine.
Doctors, doctors, doctors!
In this hospital, we share.
We share.
(woman)
Is this a bad time?
Hello, John.
Amy?
(sniffles)
(grunts)
Who got your nose?
After we parted ways,
it was ravaged by cooties.
We can sew your face
to your arm.
Sew my face to my arm?
That's the cure?
Yeah.
Are you looking at my nose?
(sobbing)
(Herman Barrow)
Right this way, Amy,
already looking good.
Awesome.
That is so cool.
Cool.
(Kid Algernon)
How did you do that? Great job.
So that's-- that's it?
I just... stay like this with
my face attached to my arm?
(agreeing enthusiastically)
You guys are here 'cause you're,
you're walking me out or...
Yup.
Oh, and don't pull
your... arm out.
It'll, like, rip it off.
Any sort of home care,
I should... worry about or...
Nope.
Just go.
All right.
All right, bye.
We're gonna keep in touch,
all right, or...
Yeah.
Okay.
(Amy)
Oh, you guys,
it does not look weird?
(all)
No, no, no.
'Cause it feels weird,
I mean, it honestly--
Ow!
Ooh...
(screaming)
Ooh.
Be careful!
Bye!